dan Patrick show brought to you by
mercedes-amg be prepared for whatever
comes your way the all-new GT 4-door
coupe because life's race vis your local
dealership for test drive today always
appreciate the insights of Shawn O'Hara
NFL Network analyst former Super Bowl
champ with the Giants who joins us now
good morning Sean I want you to go back
and put on your uniform as if you're
still a member of the Giants offensive
line how do you feel today
well I describe my head you know I'm
sure I'm gonna text threat with my
teammates saying what the world was
doing how are we letting some of our
best players walk out the door ie Landon
Collins and Olivia Vernon and now
obviously the trade went out Beckham so
I think that would be the initial
realization and then I think as cooler
heads would prevail we would kind of
come to realize that you know what we've
got a lot of holes that we've got to
fill on both sides of the ball really
mostly defense but the reality is we
haven't been a very good team and you
know what we've got to find a way to get
better and get back in the win column
and find a way to make it to the
postseason and you know I think when you
kind of see you know what's transpired
since then obviously the trade you know
you bring in your grill peppers and it's
like okay you know what
alright we can do that and then you
bring in Golden Tate and it's like okay
and we got Kevin Zeiler - all right now
we're starting to see progress and
starting to see a little bit of that
plan but I'm sure it's tough you know Oh
Dell as much as there's a lot out there
about him and his personality and all
that you know look the guys in the
locker room I mean you love them you
love having him if I'm a quarterback if
I'm Eli and I got to go in a game with a
minute 30 seconds left in the game
believe me I want 13 well I'm trying to
understand this though with the Giants
what are you gonna do with the
quarterbacking position because you
didn't take one in the quarterback draft
in the previous year
you've got a great running back and say
Quan Barkley but now you're stuck with
Eli and is last year and really no plan
moving forward
yeah it's an interesting dynamic because
I don't think Eli's ever gone into the
final year of a deal you know it's not
like the Giants to have their
quarterback kind of going into that mode
but I look at it like what we heard
gentlemen say and what we heard
schirmer's say you know at the combine
look we're counting on Eli this year and
I think the hope is that this team is
better that they win games make it to
the postseason and I think the hope is
that UI has a good year and they make
and it makes them have a tough decision
going forward I think that would be a
great problem to have if you're Dave
gentlemen but I also think they look at
well if you didn't fall in love with one
of the quarterbacks from last year I
don't know that I see it happening this
year unless you've got the number one
pick and I think they look at that and
say look maybe we take a quarterback
later on the giraffe but there isn't
somebody that they're ready to go all-in
on and when you look at the Giants and
when the season ended the first thing
that come out of the gentleman's mouth
was we've got to fix our defense we've
got to find a way to stop people get
after the quarterback this draft is
loaded with guys that can do just that
and now the fact that they were able to
pick up an extra first-round pick and
that's a third round pick I could see
them making a complete overhaul that
defense yeah I'm just not sure what
they're doing with gold and Tate you
know he's a nice second or third
receiver there and you're paying him
some pretty good money there I I don't
know I think you're either all-in on
let's rebuild get maybe the top draft
pick next year you know I don't want to
use the word tanking we don't use that
me NFL but that would be what I would be
doing I would just say all right we're
gonna pave the way and to a tongue of
Eylau is gonna be our quarterback next
year and let's just then then we start
our rebuild because I thought with Odell
and say Kwan I'd go all in on Kyler
murmuring I would make that offense
something we had never seen I'd make you
have to prepare for us and I would turn
the NFL on its ear that would have been
my approach if I was the Giants and I
was keeping everybody the defense under
they underperformed and but I would have
a dynamic offense is that asking too
much is that too far-fetched for the
Giants organization to think that way
well I think it sounds good on paper you
know and I mean that's certainly the
Cleveland model I mean that's what
they're going for they've got Baker
they've got obj they got Jarvis you know
they've gotten Joko you know I think
when I look at the Giants offense you
know I look at him innit
they had to have said all right you know
I personally don't think they were
shopping Odell but I think they got an
offer from the Browns who you know John
Dorsey took a shot and he said look what
happens and they said man we you know we
can't turn this down we've got it we've
got to make moves because the reality is
we didn't win a lot of games with Odell
went to the playoffs one time you know
you look at you know I mean who are the
top five receiver in the NFL right now
you know did any of them make the
playoffs that were any of them in the
Super Bowl you know yeah I think you
look at it like if the fact that the
Giants have sake won Berkeley that's
what enabled them to make this trade and
to make this move this offense is going
to be centered around him Golden State's
gonna be a piece of that sterling
Shepherds gonna be a part of that
everything was going to be a part of
that but you know there are people in
that building that actually felt like
wow this offense was actually pretty
good
without Odell at the end of the season
you know he didn't play the last I think
four games of the season and you know
look I think they got a little glimpse
of that you know the year before I was
hurt and I was at the bar code but this
offense you know I think as many points
is you want to score it doesn't do any
good if you're not you can't get off the
field on defense and if you can't find a
way to stop people Sean good to visit
with you as always we appreciate your
time
thanks Dan appreciate it man have a good
weekend and Shawn O'Hara NFL Network
analyst former Super Bowl champ with a
change for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]